when you left the e street band
you know it broke bruce's heart right
well i don't know about that it was a it
was mutual i mean it was a very amicable
uh split you know he understood
i wanted to just uh i was getting into
politics i wanted to learn about what's
going on in the world and i needed to
split for a while but you had been his
friend since you were little kids and it
was like he lost his arm or something i
was i i did watch his back yes i kind of
had the same job i now end up with on
the sopranos i am shocked that
gandolfini says i you know i'm sick of
the part i play tony soprano for years i
want to move on blah blah blah blah if i
was him i played that forever because
you know what it's a great part you're
never going to get another part like if
i was him i legally changed my name to
tony soprano what do you think of that
i'd actually go be in the mom
are you tired of doing it
no i would do it forever i'm i'm like
you love it right i love it i love it
but you know i'm not there you know 16
hours a day you know i mean i mean it's
murder i tell you i've had a couple
episodes where i had a big big part of
that episode one of my favorite episodes
is when you have to take over the mob
right that's what i loved and you found
the job too hard you're stressed out
that was a great angle well i'm the only
character that doesn't want to be boss
you know on the show it's great but but
you know that one that that two weeks i
mean our show went to uh what did we go
to 17 18 days of show
and those 18 days i worked almost every
day
like literally 14 16 hours a day now i
know why it goes crazy right have you
become very close to james gandolfini
yeah we all came became very cool do you
hang out with the cast members
occasionally yeah you do yeah is it
strange for you to see the thing coming
to a close i mean it's such a huge part
of your life it's such fun how to be
somebody else a couple days a week you
know i mean it's such a vacation
mentally i mean i'm going to really miss
it i mean you know what happens in the
end of many of you you got to everything
they don't keep anything secret from you
no no i've known for all year yeah have
you seen the final episodes i never saw
the final episode uh done because we see
just little glimpses of it you know
right uh i see at the same time
everybody else does really i mean the
final was it tough killing adriana was
it hard for you that was one of the best
ever very hard episodes very hard we
were very rough honestly it wasn't you
know the shooting of course you shoot
somebody whatever but when you have to
put your hands on a girl okay i mean it
looks easy on the screen it's not easy
you got to really be that guy for that
minute because you got to get sick it's
so nauseating how did you start acting
why did why do you think david chase the
creator of the sopranos chased you for
10 years to be this character why 10
years like what was it about you
have you ever studied acting no i mean
he wasn't within 10 years he just i
think he saw me on a tv show uh
inducting the rascals in the rock roll
hall of fame right and happened to be
casting that week and said let's let's
try him out you know i don't know what
he saw i mean it's funny how he saw you
as a mobster because we know you from
the eastern certainly nothing like that
i know i know isn't it weird that he saw
you and you figured you'd be a good
mobster yes it was very weird he's a
he's just one of those guys that just
sees things differently you know i think
partly came from our
the relationship we had in the street
band we were we were not faceless
nameless sidemen you know we were all
characters absolutely and we were kind
of like the rock and roll rat pack in a
way right um
you know me playing the dean martin roll
and
clarence being a very big sammy davis
were you the first guy were you the
first guy uh assigned to the sopranos
no no um
i don't know what the order was really
right but when i got there you know i
started he said i want you in the show
and i i said to him you know i got to
tell you the truth i feel a little bit
weird taking another actor's role you
know because these guys work their whole
life right they go to school you know so
once i said that to david about about
taking an actor's job he said you know
what i'll write you in a part so you're
not taking anybody's job which was nice
oh no that's good all right do you know
any any real mob guys no i i i wouldn't
be real if i really realized
you said that no i know the answer is
yes
i was asking because you research a
little bit you know you know guys who
know guys who know guys and isn't it
amazing i mean they portray this so well
how killing is just like taking a dump
if you want you know what i mean it's
like it's just not a big deal you don't
sit there and wrestle with your
conscience
it's usually insiders you know i mean
they they really do you know in the old
days anyway they try to stay in the mob
so it's somebody who was uh owed a lot
of money you know wasn't paying their
bills in your personal life have you
actually killed anyone i mean you know
by accident or otherwise i wanted to
you